I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight thanks for
joining us
Dumb Dumber dumbest that is the focus of
tonight's angle
all right sadly stupidity has become the
fastest growing industry in America
today and nowhere is this more evident
than in the academic world
now consider the latest embarrassing
Revelation from the land of higher
education
at Vanderbilt one of the hottest
universities in the country two
associate Deans at the Peabody school's
office of equity diversity and inclusion
were caught doing something that would
get most students tossed out
after the tragic killings at Michigan
State University Nicole Joseph and
Hasina mahutan felt the need to send out
a campus-wide email to reflect on the
shooting
one problem
they use the artificial intelligence app
chat GPT to write it for them
well no big surprise right that the bot
used the typical liberal Dei blather and
redundant expressions
this was part of it the recent Michigan
shootings are a tragic reminder of the
importance of taking care of each other
particularly in the context of creating
inclusive environments
now these women were so sloppy and so
lazy that they didn't notice the small
print at the end of the actual letter
which read
paraphrase from open ai's chat GPT AI
language model personal communication
February 15 2023.
no whoops the school has since
apologized Dumb and Dumber
well they obviously didn't read the
piece recently published in the Atlantic
by Ian bogus titled chat GPT is dumber
than you think well in a moment we're
going to explain how it's not just
dumber than you think but more biased
than you think as well
but in a statement Vanderbilt's dean of
the education School Kamala benbau said
her office is quote conducting a
complete review of the sequence of
events
that led to sending the email and noted
that the two deanlets will quote step
back from their responsibilities step
back
one Dean said that although she stood by
the bot sentiment urging that
inclusiveness well she did admit to
plagiarizing and apologized okay
how does either of them still have a job
at the University
let's not forget by the way a little
over 10 years ago Vanderbilt kicked all
the Christian groups off campus unless
non-christians were allowed to lead the
group this is the kind of Brilliance
that Vanderbilt these days
the diversity equity and inclusion traps
are everywhere on CNN today reporter and
anchor a reporter and anchor were
implicitly calling for quotas in the
field of Medicine
right now fewer than six percent of
doctors in the U.S identifies black or
African-American more needs to be done
to make sure that our physician worked
for us here in the U.S reflects the
diversity seen among patients patients
are more likely to follow a physician's
medical advice if they do have a feeling
of being heard and understood so all
this plays a role in really improving
Public Health
they showed a chart with all the you
know 0.2 percent Native American doctors
point you get the point
but question do anyone does anyone out
there think any politicians on Capitol
Hill or any Fortune 500 CEOs that they
choose doctors when they're in a real
emergency situation based on diversity
considerations like for heart surgery
let's say
or do they choose their doctors based on
reputation and Merit
now this equity and diversity nonsense
it's not making us better it's not
making us smarter it's not making us
stronger or more united as a nation it's
making us Dumber weaker and more divided
the result kids can't read or do Math
teachers are afraid to establish
objective standards they don't want to
offend any parents and administrators
like those at Vanderbilt those women
can't be bothered to compose or
proofread their own emails
and remember those two denlets represent
Vanderbilt's Peabody School of Education
in other words training the next
generation of thinkers talk about
terrifying
there are some signs though that this
system is beginning to break down
notice that some of the first positions
being cut by businesses right now during
this economic slowdown are the diversity
departments and Consultants
a plainly put there's no value there
teaching young people resentment and
rage it's a dead end no matter how you
look at it
if they fall into the mindset that
everything is rigged that America is
systemically racist in other words Joe
Biden's View
it's only going to ensure failure and
despair and hatred as one's own country
the Deans at Vanderbilt came out of the
Dei mindset and they were trained in
racial and ethnic glibness where results
don't matter only the process matters
and this thinking we know has come to
dominate the entire Democratic Party
it's dominated the Biden White House and
democrat-run states
and look what's happening to them are
they flourishing
now if we succumb to the Dei mindset
it's not just New York and California
that are going to be left behind but all
of America
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else